NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's get started.
Today we're going to be
talking about preflop, which
is the last thing
I definitely want
to cover before the
[? Sakuna ?] tournament.
As you know, this is going to
be one of my last lectures.
I'm teaching one or to
over the next two weeks,
but we're primarily
going to have
guest speakers talking
about more the macro poker
environment.
So why are we doing preflop?
So in tournaments,
most of your value
is going to come from
what you do preflop--
playing it close to optimally.
And the reason is
because a lot of people
don't do this good at all.
Like they really,
really play preflop
badly because it's
very counter intuitive.
Especially live.
Like people have a
much tougher time
doing this because
either they're
afraid of getting knocked
down on a bad hand,
or their afraid of
showing down a bad hand,
or live players are
just worse in general.
So for whatever reason,
people screw this up online.
A little bit on live a lot.
In addition, one of
the reasons that we're
spending an entire day on it is
it's relatively easier to solve
from a mathematical standpoint.
Like we get close to
a Nash equilibrium
because there aren't
that many variables.
Whereas postflop, there
are a million variables.
It's more related to kind of
putting things into patterns
that you might be close to.
So that's why I'm doing this.
And then let's start
with a scenario
that we're going to be analyzing
for the rest of the class.
There we go.
So here's our scenario.
So I'm-- how it works heads up
is the dealer button is a small
blind.
That's a slight
break in the rules
because you assume I'm
button, he's small blind,
I'm big blind, but they
change around a little bit.
This way, the button isn't the
last one to act every round.
So here, I'm first one to
act preflop and then last
to act every round thereafter.
If I were big blind, I'd
be less every single round.
So it's a minor variation that
you guys should just know.
So situation-- I'm
small blind for 125,
he's big blind for
150, and there's
a 25 ante, which is why
there's 50 in the pot.
And the question is
what do we do here?
OK, so we have 9-6
offsuit with 2 1/2 m.
We're in the small
blind, and we're trying
to figure out what do we do.
So the answer here might
not be that intuitive,
and I don't think I'd
give it to you right away.
But how we figure it out is
just with a normal semi-bluffing
equation.
We take a look at-- OK,
so everything preflop
is a semi-bluff because we
have some chance of winning,
and we're virtually
never less than 30%.
So we just use this
semi-bluffing formula
that we've seen before
where our EV is just
going to be the pot times
the chance he folds,
plus the chance he doesn't fold
times our EV when he calls.
We need to figure out some
sort of calling range.
I just made up one
here that seemed
like about at the pro level,
and this is pretty wide.
Like him calling with like
Ace-2 or Jack-10 or 2-2.
This is a wideish range.
I think a lot of players
for the tournament life
might not call this
wide, but it ends up
being like 27.6% of
hands he's calling.
So we're going to
use it as a baseline,
and then later we'll show
why that doesn't matter.
So our question is, what's
our equity versus range here?
And what we can do there is
just plug into PokerTracker.
So the idea is we
don't know what
hand he has and we don't care.
It's unrealistic to think
that we can get down
to any sort of hand
he'll be calling with,
but we can get down to a range.
We can say he's
equally likely to have
any assortment of the hands in
that range because if he calls,
that means that he has
one of those hands.
So we can compare our equity
versus any one of those hands
to get our equity
versus range, and we
can do that in PokerTracker.
So what you're going to do
is you're going to open up
the equity calculator, you're
going to put in 9-6 off,
and then you're
going to put in this.
I actually just
drew it in there,
but that's the same
thing I showed before,
which is pocket 2s are better.
Ace-2, King-2 , Queen-- sorry.
King-10, Queen-10,
Jack-10, and then the same
for offsuit, which
is the representation
of this entire thing.
I just need to separate
offsuit or suited,
and then I assumed by jack-10,
it meant that entire corner,
although PokerTracker
likes specifying.
Anyway, so this is
our equity versus.
This is saying that
if we go in with 9-6
and he calls with
anything in that range,
we are 34% to win this hand.
So I don't know if that's
about what you'd expect.
It seems higher than I would
have thought initially,
but that's our
equity verses range.
If we go all in and
he calls, we can
assume we're a 35-65
underdog without even
knowing what he has.
And then once we
find out what he has,
we will find out whether we're
slightly better or worse,
but that doesn't really matter.
So we can calculate our EV
in this hand in the same way
that we're used to
calculating semi-bluffing.
The EV of the push
is going to be this.
The chance of him
folding times 425.
If he calls 27%
of the time, that
means he folds whatever this
is like 73% of the time.
So that's our value from him
folding-- the fold equity.
And then 20% of the time
we're in a showdown situation
where of that [? push ?]
time that he calls,
we're 35 to win 1250 and
we're 65 to lose 950,
resulting in a
total equity of 253.
So that's a lot of
chips for what might
seem like a very marginal move.
By going all in
here, you're actually
making that many chips.
And in fact, a more
provocative way
to describe it is if
you don't do this,
you are losing 250 chips.
You only need 1,000 to
win this whole tournament,
and by folding what seems
like a very weak hand
in this position, you are just
giving him 250 chips of value.
So that's a lot, and that shows
how counterintuitive this is.
That a situation where
you have really bad cards,
you don't realize that
these are actually really,
really good cards
in the situation.
In fact, no matter
what, your cards
are basically good
in this situation.
Because this situation makes
any two cards good enough.
So let's talk about-- so we
made one assumption, which
is what his call range is.
Did you have a question?
Oh, OK.
So we made some assumption about
what his call range is, and I
said it didn't matter.
Why?
Because what we can do here is
make the call range a variable.
So this fold percent
is a variable,
and then our win percent
is related to the percent
that he folds.
Because if he calls a small
range of hands when we get
called, he's going
to be crushing us.
Whereas if he calls
like 90% of the time,
we're probably
ahead of his range
because he calls a
lot of worse hands.
Anyway, so you can
take a graph and just
look, OK, he calls somewhere
between 0% of the time
in 100% of the time, and then we
can do this EV equation for all
those hands by
calculating OK, so what's
our equity versus calling range?
This doesn't change.
We still win or lose the
same amount every time.
And say so if we were
always pushing here,
if he calls with whatever
range, this is our EV.
And then one thing
that's interesting
about this graph is what?
It's always
positive, which means
that no matter what his calling
range is, this push is good.
It might be more
intuitive this way.
Like if he folds
100% of the time--
if he only calls 0% of
the time, we trend up
to a number around here.
And what number's around here?
That's just this.
It's the pot before
we do anything.
So if he folds 100% of the
time, we just win the pot.
Like that's our EV every
hand, and it just trends
based on this.
Where the more he calls,
typically the better the worse
our EVs going to be.
Yes?
[? Yes. ?] We'll get to that.
And that's a good
question, although it's
going to take us half
the class to answer that.
Anyway, so that's
a cool thing here.
So it's always
positive, which means
I'm saying-- no matter what
his-- the villain does, always,
always push all in with 9-6
offsuit in this position.
So let's break it
down into components.
So to explain
intuitively what drives
this graph is your equity
there is split into two parts
because it's a semi-bluff.
It's your fold equity
and your showdown equity.
So let's turn this into lines.
So you see your fold equity
just decreases the more
he calls in a linear fashion.
So that should be
fairly intuitive.
The proportion he calls
reduces your fold equity
by that amount, and then
your showdown equity
has a little curve
here where you
get more value from the showdown
on average the more he calls.
The only reason there's
a little bit of curvature
is because it's multiplied
by the chances of him
calling in the first plAce.
So it's tilting
in some direction.
But anyway, these are curved.
Makes this a very interesting
optimization puzzle.
And the reason we're positive
at the end is for this reason.
We're basically-- so this
line, the total equity,
is just the sum of these two.
Where our showdown
value is going
to be negative over
basically this entire range.
Even when our fold
equity reaches zero,
that's when our showdown
equity creeps just above zero.
Regardless of what
his calling range is,
your average is like
175 chips of EV.
Like the 20% call--
or whatever we said.
The 27% calling range
isn't necessarily optimal.
He knows you have these cards.
But on average, you're
getting-- whatever,
like 100 and something chips.
And just to show
how bad is folding,
if you just open fold
this for some reason,
that's as bad as
purposely calling it all
in with 3-4 versus Ace-King.
Like that's an equivalent
amount of EV loss
as folding this hand.
So now let's talk about how
hard this is going to be.
So push/fold
decisions are really
hard to kind of
intuitively figure out
just because of the curvature
and the steepness of those
graphs are moving
in weird directions
and they're both moving at
the same time with regard
to all the other variables.
So it makes it so that
it's very hard to come up
with very quick rules.
Some variables are going
to affect our decision,
and the result is
either push or fold.
Our result isn't
even as complicated
as betting a certain
amount, but the variables
you have to consider are our
cards, our position, our stack,
and the villain's
call range, which
results in this
five-dimensional ray that we
have to slice and dice so that
we have our push/fold decision
range.
So what we want to do is
isolate for specific things.
We want to say OK, let's take--
let's make this and this static
so that we can
solve for these two,
or let's make these two static
so we can solve for these two.
So we can end up with a chart
that looks something like this.
And this is a little
bit more manageable.
We can just say this green
area is when you should push
and this yellow area is
when you should fold.
That's our goal here.
To be able to develop
that sort of chart.
And then figure out what's
the best thing to isolate.
So let's get to it.
So range is the
postset of hands.
This is how you write it.
This is the assumption
that we're making.
So we're doing it
for two reasons.
Analyzing our opponent, which
we're not going to be doing.
We're going to assume we
have no information about him
because it's preflop, and a lot
of it-- one of our assumptions
is that he hasn't
even acted yet, so we
have no information at all.
But we're going to be using
it to determine our plays.
Basically we're saying we
have some sort of decision
[INAUDIBLE] for our range.
Like we certainly can't solve
this for every single hand
or at least we can't remember
it, so what we're going to do
is come up with a line
where we say every hand
above that certain line, i.e.
That range above
that line, is going
to be good for our
specific decision.
And we're bringing
these into percentiles,
and that's how we're
going to describe them.
And we're using
Sklansky-Carlson.
His rankings for our
breakdown of percentiles.
But here's his
original question,
and this is just to explain
where these come from
and why this is particularly
relevant to what we're doing.
So his question is
you're the small blind
and you have a choice
between either folding
or open pushing a hand, or open
pushing here means you push
and you show your hand
before he makes a call.
And the question is how
many chips is this good for?
If you have one chip, or
I guess we have two chips,
you have since they're 1-2
blinds, if you have two chips
and one is already in the small
blind, your pot odds are 25%.
So even if he knows--
he's going to call
if he's anything more
than a 50% favorite,
so you have the odds to do that
with at least a pretty bad hand
and a lot of good hands.
So x here is how
big can your stack
be before this starts
becoming unprofitable?
And the answer for Ace-Ace
offsuit is about 70,
and to explain how
we got to that,
we're going to make
a couple assumptions.
And you can see
the clear relation
between this methodology
and what we're doing.
So 1-2 blinds-- here a
small blind with whatever.
Here are bets x all in.
And we're going to
say big blind's going
to call when EV's more than 50.
Which he might do pot odds,
which we're just going
to ignore now for simplicity.
We're just going to say
big blind is calling
when he's more than 50% to win.
It's actually zero when
he has the pot odds, which
is this equation, but we're
going to forget about that.
Let's just say he's
going to only call
with literal better hands.
So here he's going
to call with Ace-8
or pocket 2's because
we have Ace-8.
He's going to call with a
pocket pair, which is always
going to be better,
and Ace-8, which
is going to be equal or better.
So that's his calling
range 13% of the time.
So we win 33% for
this range, which
is you just plug-in
to the PokerTracker
and it'll give you that
you're a 30% underdog, which
is what I did here.
That's how you do it.
And we get our EV
from the situation,
and we have to solve for x.
So we want EV to be 0 because
we're finding the marginal EV,
and this is what we get.
We get x, which is
all the chips we
had before we paid
the big blind,
and we lose x minus 1, which
is all the chips we have
after paying the small blind.
So a little bit of
nuance there and only
changes our number by one, but
that gives us our break even.
And our break even
here is like 62x.
So the reason it's
a little bit lower
is it doesn't factor in the
big blind doing pot odds,
but that's the idea.
So what we're going to do
is we're going to solve this
and we're not going to do it.
Someone else did it.
We're going to solve this
for every single hand,
and this is what Sklansky did.
So he figured what your number
here is going to be two things.
The number of hands you
are slightly better than,
and why is this
factor important?
What's he going to do it if you
have a better hand than him?
He's going to fold.
So this determines
our fold equity,
and then chance of
winning when you're behind
determines our equity when
he actually does call.
He just has perfect
information which
is why it's a little
bit of a change
and we're able to solve
it out perfectly here.
So Sklansky didn't
know how to program,
which is why Scott Carlson, or
Victor Chubukov a couple days
later-- apparently
later the same day-
came up with the answer.
Where he said Aces have
infinity value here
where you can have an
unlimited amount of chips
and then show Aces and push
them, and it's plus EV.
We're not saying it's the
most optimal decision,
but you won't actually lose
chips on average even if you
have an unlimited chip stack.
Whereas King, it only
works for 1,290 chips.
So we can solve it for
every hand to get down to,
you could do this with 3-2
off with 1.8 chips and so on.
So this is our primary
way to rank hands,
and we're assuming that at
least in a heads-up situation,
this is a pretty good
idea of what hands
will have the most
value especially when it
comes to going all in.
One other method is going to
be equity versus three randoms,
and it might be more
relevant for multi-way pots.
You just rank them
by their expectation
against three callers who
haven't looked at their hand.
But we're not going to do
that especially because we're
assuming generally we're going
to get one caller, especially
heads-up where you
can only get one.
But we're going to
expand it out later.
So just an example
of what these are.
Top 1% is Aces, top 5%
is 10s and Ace-Queens.
30% is this.
And sorry to break
it to you guys,
but you're going to
have to memorize these.
So 5% you just remember
their premium hands, just ten
or Ace Queens, and I'm
giving you little mnemonics
to help you remember it.
Like Ace-10 or better
is 10%, and then
like some sort of pocket pairs--
it's not even that big of deal
if you go down to 2s here.
20% is Ace-2 or pocket 2's.
That's how you're
going to remember it.
And then 30% is Broadway, so
Broadway is any two fAce cards.
And an intuitive way to think
about it is based on this.
Broadway is just this corner
here, which is about 1/3
of the graph when you
count in pocket pairs.
So that's how you just remember
30%-- it's that corner.
So it's not that bad.
Just remember top
20% is Ace-2 and 2s.
30% is Broadway, and then
10% is Ace-10-- not that bad.
So 50% is just going to be
the diagonal on the graph.
It's any two cards
adding up to 15.
This is what I mean
by the diagonal.
Like this is your 13-by-13
graph where these are offsuit
and these are suited, which
is why we double count them.
And then this hand
adds up to 15.
Ace-two and so does King-3
and so does Queen-4.
So this is your 50th
percentile hand.
So that's how you're
going to remember that.
And then you don't really
need to remember anything
more than that.
So 100% is going to
be any two cards.
It's going to be the
entire graph here.
So we're going to be
talking about-- yeah?
Percentage is the
percent of hands
that that range represents.
So like this is the
top 10% of hands.
So if he calls--
if we assume he's
going to call 10%
of the time, we
are saying that he will
call with these cards
and these cards only.
And we're going to be
talking about ranges
from now on because it helps us
understand what cards he has,
to some extent, but
also lets us use it
as an idea to get-- to figure
out exactly how often he's
going to call.
So we're just going to
be talking about ranges,
and this is what I
mean when I say ranges.
And to the extent that you're
just doing this at the table,
you just have to memorize
these three numbers.
Because this is
easy, this is easy,
and then just remember
that tens are our 5%.
When we're talking
about ranges in general,
a plus EV range--
a decision that's
good for a range means that
on average, your decision is
profitable for every hand
for that range in general.
But an optimal range is
profitable for literally
every hand.
So you can do a
lot of things that
are profitable
for any two cards,
but 3-2 off might actually
not be profitable.
So it's not necessarily optimal.
You want to make sure that
every [INAUDIBLE] you can,
every single card in
that range is optimal
and is profitable, which
gives you the optimal range.
It's the most plus EV range
for that type of decision.
An example of this
is-- so say you're
playing against Ace-Queen
and you call with this range.
Pocket 5's and Ace-10 or better.
So you are ahead of
this [INAUDIBLE] Queen
because you're 53% to win
the hand with this range.
However, we know
it's not optimal
because we're calling
with two losing hands--
Ace-10 and Ace-jack.
So a more realistic,
more optimal
range is going to be pocket
2s and Ace-King or better.
So that's going to be
the difference there.
So I want to make sure we're
not solving for something that's
a slight favorite when actually
missing out on something
a little bit more optimal.
Here we go, so this
is a better range.
5-5 or Ace-Queen,
actually 2s or Ace-Queen
would be a little bit better,
and we win 60% of the time.
And then if a range
is optimal, then
we know for every
hand in that range,
we have a plus EV decision.
And that's why this
is the action we're
going to use to prove that
if we solve for a range,
then we know that if you
have any card in that range,
our rule is still good for it.
So that's why I'm
showing you that.
Right, so that's it.
So that's all we're
going to do in terms
of defining what ranges are
and how we got those numbers.
And from now, we're going to
talk about making decisions
based on a range.
So let's talk about preflops.
Our assumption is hero
has M less than 10.
We're in that period
of the tournament
where your M is not
going to be that high.
The villain is calling
some percentage
of hands that are presumably
the top whatever of hands.
We're guessing he's not
calling with a worse hand
then-- and folding better hands.
[INAUDIBLE]
He might be a little
bit-- his view of what
are good hands and
bad hands might
be a little bit off of
ours, but we're just
assuming everyone has the same.
[? ICM ?] doesn't
matter, so we don't care
about payout in tournaments.
We're just trying to maximize
our chip-- our chip EV,
and we only have two
decisions-- push or call.
So the way that we're going
to come up with this rule
here for heads-up is--
so what we're doing
is we want to figure out
what our push/fold range is
for heads-up in every scenario.
And the way that we're
going to do this is first,
we need an equation that tells
us range for range equities.
So everyone can figure out Aces
versus whatever is like 80-20,
and then 2 over cards with
a pocket pair is 50-50ish.
But we want to know what's
a range versus a range.
Like if we push 70%
of the time and he
calls 30% of the time,
what does that translate to
in terms of our equity?
And it ends up being
like 60/40, but we
want to get an idea of what
that trend is because that's
going to materially change
our ability to come up
with an optimal solution here.
So we want to build a table
of range versus range,
and then we come up
with a formula that
will let us put in
two ranges and come up
with an equity calculation
for both of those ranges.
Then we're going
to develop an EV
model for semi-bluffs,
which we already did,
so that should be quick.
For each m, find Nash
equilibrium if one exists.
So a lot of people-- if you
Google "Nash equilibrium"
for a preflop, you'll find
something, it's wrong,
and later I'll show you why.
And therefore,
unstable equilibriums--
it pretty much always is.
Find a reasonable
range and figure out
what kind of assumptions
we need to make
to make our push/fold
decisions correct.
So let's do this first thing.
So if we just-- for
each-- say that we
use a hero's range of 50%.
So in PokerTracker, we
put top 50% of hands.
And then for each range
of hands for the villain,
we calculate the
equity for that.
And we do that for whatever I
did, like 15 different ranges.
So if we push 50% of the time
and he calls 50% of the time,
what's our equity?
What's our chance of winning?
50, right.
So we have an even
equity because we
are pushing and calling the
same types of hands on average.
Whereas if he calls
100% of the time,
our equity's actually
closer to 60.
We are the favorite-- we are
a 60/40 favorite on that hand.
Whereas if he calls with just
Aces, then we are like 17%
to win the hand.
That's the idea.
So our goal here is to come
up with some sort of equation
that we can just plug-in
to-- we can do math on.
Like we want to be able
to do calculus on it,
so we need an equation.
So what type of
function does this look
like because we want to
try to fit a curve to it.
Exactly.
It seems like a
logarithmic function
and within r squared
of 99, it says
that that's the logarithmic
equation for it.
So that works when
the range is 50%,
but let's take a look at when
we change the range to 30%.
So what this is saying is we
are pushing 30% of the time
and he is calling x
percent of the time.
And what this line is our chance
of winning when he does that,
and this is also logarithmic.
So we're seeing a
little bit of a pattern,
and then it also has a
really good r squared.
And then if we push
10% of the time,
it still like, OK,
it's 98 and change
when we look at our equities
versus his calling range.
But then it starts to get bad.
If he calls 5% of
the time, our r
squared when we fit a
log normal function,
or a logarithmic
function, is only 95.
And if he only calls 3% of
the time, our r squared is 89.
Like this is not
really lot logarithmic
when we start getting
in very tight ranges.
And in 1%, it sucks.
It's not even close.
So what we're trying to
do is develop an equation
for figuring out
range versus ranges,
and we see that logarithmic
works some of the time.
So the reason it
doesn't work, just
to give you kind of an
idea why it doesn't work,
is because the top 1%
of hands is three hands.
It's Aces, Ace-King, and Kings.
So it's materially changing
based on whether he's-- if we
push Ace-King, whether he calls
with only Aces or Kings or also
Ace-King jumps us
between here and here.
So we have huge
gaps when it comes
to very tight
percentages, so that's why
we break a little bit up here.
And when we turn it around, we
have the same type of thing.
This is looking at OK,
say that we know he's
going to call 50% of the time.
If we push x
percent of the time,
what is our chance of winning?
So if we 100% of the time
and he calls 40% of the time,
then we are 40% to win.
So that's what this
chart is telling us,
and you see the same
type of pattern.
Where 50% range versus
this kind of range is good.
If we push whatever and
he calls 30% of the time,
it's still good.
But then if he calls 2% of the
time, it starts becoming bad.
So what are we taking
away from this?
And the whole plan is we want
to come up with an equation that
just gives us these numbers.
I only got these from pushing
them into PokerTracker
and were trying to fit a
certain equation onto it.
So our takeaways here
is that like range
versus range relationship
is probably logarithmic.
That seems to be
a good estimate,
but it's definitely
not good in the top 5%.
So with regard to
our model, we're
just going to say
this is probably not
that good when you're
talking about ranges in 5%.
But realistically,
when m is less than 10,
no one is do anything
in the 5% range,
so it's not that big of
a deal just to ignore it.
So what we did is we
populated this table just now.
So we took a look at what's
the villain's range up here
and what's our range?
So when we push 100% of the time
and he calls 30% of the time,
we win 39% of the time.
Where red means that we are
not likely to win and green
means that we are likely to win.
Like when we push 5% and
he calls with anything,
we're 73% to win.
So that's what this
table is telling us,
and we want to do is we want to
come up with an equation that
lets us populate this table
without actually having
to do the range versus
range calculations by hand.
So what I did was I
just ran a regression
based on logarithmic variables,
and I found something
that I found to be
really, really cool.
So these seem to
be the coefficients
with an r squared of 98.
So this equation seems
to basically nail
these range versus range
equities, which is, I think,
really cool.
So our guess is probably a
reason that it starts at 50%,
and it seems to be symmetrical.
Which is-- I don't
know if there's
a statistical reason
for that, but that's
extremely fascinating.
And it could make
sense intuitively
that-- so this is your
chance of winning.
So would it make sense
that the wider he calls--
when we take the natural log of
the percentage of him calling,
our percent win goes up.
So I think it does
because it means
he's calling with a worse hand.
That's why it goes up
when he calls greater,
but then goes down when we
push greater because this means
that we're pushing worse hands.
So that's the equation
there, and that's
giving us something that we
can actually differentiate when
we're trying to solve this.
And just in terms of
errors, it's not that bad.
We have an r squared of 98.
So I think this is
good enough to use.
We can actually use
this to try to optimize
our decision making preflop.
So we solved-- we came
up with an equation
that we can use for determining
our chance of winning
a hand compared to our pushing
range and his calling range.
So let's go back to our
EV model for semi-bluff.
So we already did that in
the fold equity portion,
but we're going
to build this out
to be relevant to our
situation in particular.
So we're assuming we're
talking about in terms of M,
so what's our-- so our blinds
are going to be equal to 1.
Like this means this is 1 M and
our EV is going to be in terms
of M's.
We're going to-- if our
EV ends up being 0.35,
it means 0.35 times all
the blinds combined just
to get rid of blinds here.
So all the blinds
combined equals
M. Our showdown
value is just going
to be-- so our fold
equity is going
to be the pot times the
chance of him folding, i.e.
1 minus calling.
The chance of him--
our showdown value
is chance of calling times win
amount times win percentage
minus lose amount
times lose percentage.
The win amount is going
to be stacked plus 2/3
because if the blinds are
1-2 or something where
the big blind is
double the small blind,
it means that you
win his big blind
and then you lose
your whole stack.
Depending on when
we mark our stack,
it changes it a
little bit with regard
to whether we count it as before
we pay the blind or after.
But it ends up not
making a huge difference.
It just impacts whether
this is plus 2/3 or plus
1/3 or just your stack.
But anyway, we also
have this equation,
which we just solve for.
Where the chance
of us winning is
related to the
chance to him calling
and the range that
we're pushing.
So what you might
see here is all
of these are related to the
same three variables, where it's
either the call
percentage, the push
percentage, or a stack size.
So we combine this to one giant
equation, which obviously we're
not going to remember but we
can use to start solving this
mathematically.
So this is what we
would end up with.
So when M is 1, we end up
with this sort of graph.
When the hero's push
range goes up to 100%
here and the villain's call
range goes up to 100% here.
This is our equity,
which I just color-coded
so we don't need to
look at the numbers.
Where green means it's in
the hero's favor and yellow
means it's close to
zero and red means
it's in the villain's favor.
So what we see here is
it's really green over here
and really yellow over there.
And this is telling
us this is already
factoring in fold equity and our
chance of winning if he calls.
This is saying that if
we call 100% of the time,
he should call 100%
of the time because he
wants the yellowest area and
we want the greenest area.
So that's with 1 M, so it
shouldn't be surprising
that our equilibrium
at 1 M is going
to be everyone like getting
all in 100% of the time.
We see when we switch to 10
M, it's pretty different.
In fact, this 100 is one
of the yellowest areas,
whereas our green area is
either up here or down here.
So we're going to
use this to get
an idea of how our
value changes based
on these variables
changing to figure out
if we can isolate it to a corner
and make that our kind of rule.
So first, let's find out when
we can get a Nash equilibrium.
So the villain
gets to pick this.
The villain gets to
pick his call range
and we get to pick
our push range.
That's the flexibility
each person has.
So if we push 100% of the time
and he calls 100% of the time,
this is a Nash
equilibrium for 1 M
because he can't do
any better by going up
here because a higher
number is worse for him
because this is our
equity in the hand.
And the equity comes
directly from him
because it's a heads-up
situation whereas we can't
do better by pushing left.
Like when we go down
here, the next number
is 0.32, meaning that
if we push any less,
we're actually losing
value because we
want the number to be higher.
And when it comes to 2 M,
100% isn't that much off.
We're talking about 0.01
M of a difference in EV,
but we do actually reach a
Nash equilibrium here-- 2 M--
where we can't do anything
any better by moving
and he can't do any
better by moving.
So when M is 3, we
have an unstable Nash,
and this is when stuff
is getting interesting.
If we push 80, he
should call 100.
If he calls 100, we
should push 65, and so on.
So we end up in a
bit of a circle.
It's a rock, paper,
scissors situation.
What do we have?
M equals 3.
So this lets us know that
this whole Nash equilibrium
thing is not going to work out.
Like it only really
works for M of 2,
and that's not the most
important situation
to figure out
because you're know
that you should be pushing
a very, very wide range when
M is 2.
So we need to figure out
some sort of pattern.
How do these colors move
when your M is more than 2?
So let's make-- let's
go to M equals 5
and make the gradient
a little bit steeper.
So these are the same numbers
except I just made it--
we're talking about very
slight changes in EV, where
the difference between yellow
here and green here is 0.1 M,
and this will help us
understand where this value is
going to come from.
So let's see how this
changes over time,
because our goal here
is-- the villain's goal
is to cause this to
be in a yellow area,
and the hero's goal is to cause
this to be in a green area.
And you can see
why we inherently
have this need to figure out
what they're going to do.
Because say that
we're the villain.
If we know the hero
pushes 100, we call 100.
Whereas if we think the hero
pushes 30%, we should call 5%.
So let's see how this
changes over time.
So this is when M
is 2, and then this
is us increasing as M
is 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
We're trying to
pick the box that
is kind of the yellowest area.
Where can we
realistically come up
with a rule for ending up there?
Based on what this
x-coordinate is, what
should be our y-coordinate?
What should be our call?
Do we see any way to
figure this thing out?
So what I think we should do
is just draw a line right here
and say let's just figure out
what the equation of that line
is, and then come up
with an estimate of what
his pushing range is, and then
throw it into whatever function
we used to get that line.
Which can't be very complicated
in order to make sure,
no matter what his pushing
range is that we read him for,
we end up in this yellow area.
So what I did was for each M, I
highlighted what the lowest EV
decision is for the hero,
meaning the best decision
for the villain.
And for 10 M, it's
this diagonal.
But for 1 M, it's all
the way down here.
Like best you can
do is over here.
So are our function is we call
10 times his pushing range.
So if we have 1 M and he
pushes 5% of the time,
we call about 50% of the time.
If he pushes 20% of the
time, we're calling always,
and anything more than
20%, we're always calling.
That's where M equals 1.
In general, the rule is going
to be if M is 1, always call,
and if M is 2, you call
twice his pushing range.
So if we think he's pushing 50%
or more, we're always calling.
If we think he's pushing
20%, we call 40% of the time.
Like that's the
optimal calling range
in this heads-up situation.
So when M is 4-- so I
skipped one, but when M is 4
we have basically this
straight diagonal.
We try to match
his pushing range.
So when he pushes
60, we call 60.
When he pushes 100, we call 100.
That's the best we can do
to dominate his range there.
When M is 6, we
call 2/3 his range.
And when M is 9, we
call half is range.
So those are the
rules that we're just
going to have to remember.
When you're in a
heads-up situation,
if the stack is basically 1 or
2, you're always calling him.
At 4, you're calling
him an even amount.
At 6 and 9, you're calling him
like half of what he pushes.
And that's the optimal move.
That is how you will-- if you're
in a heads-up situation, which
you will be at the end of
every tournament to the extent
that you get there, you will
dominate his playing style
based on what you read
as his pushing amount.
And you can just
count how many hands
did he push versus
how many hands
does he fold to get an idea
of what his range is here.
And this also works
when it's folded
to you in the small blind.
Like even if you're
10 handed, by the time
you get to the small blind,
you're heads up again
and these rules apply.
So to the extent
you can memorize
this thing will give you the
right move in that scenario
for Ms up to 10.
So when you're the hero-- when
you're the small but, rather,
and you're pushing, it
requires you to estimate
what his calling range is.
Because you end up all
over the plAce based
on making different estimates
of what you can call with,
and you really don't
have any information.
But I'm going to
graph it out here
and then we can see what's
going to be a good estimate
in basically any scenario.
So there are a couple different
ways I can think about this.
So we're going to come up
with a bunch of numbers
based on the villains'
call range here.
And we can either-- so
we're targeting a column
and then like the
row is going to be
information we don't have.
So the question is do
we pick the column that
has the highest average
EV, the highest minimum EV,
or the highest EV versus
like a particular bad player
that we're going
to be targeting?
And the blue here is what
column maximizes your EV
for that scenario?
And your guess is
as good as mine
when it comes to what's the
best way to strategize it.
Are we looking for-- maximizing
the min will help us make sure
that we're not dominated
by someone who's really
got our number, whereas
maximizing the average
might be better when
we're trying to figure out
against a player we know nothing
about what would be better.
And maximizing versus
tight-- or loose--
will help us figure out some
sort of-- how to capitalize
on the reads that we're making.
So when M is 1, he's over there.
No matter what the
scenario, you should
be pushing 100% of the time.
That's what this is telling us.
It shouldn't be a surprise based
on all the stuff I told you
about 1 M situations.
No matter what kind of
assumption we're making,
push 100%.
So let me pick up to M is 10.
So what's going on here?
So as M increases, they all
kind of move at the same time,
except what?
If we're talking loose or
we're targeting best/worst case
scenario or best
average, it starts
to trickle down to like 50%.
But it's certainly-- they're
relatively near each other,
and what's good about
this is that means
that if we target any of these,
we're basically in the ballpark
where the difference between
this column and this column
for any of M is going
to be not that material.
If you were just
in that ballpark,
you're fine, but which one of
them is completely different.
Yeah, against a tight player.
And it should make
sense intuitively
why if you read him as tight,
as someone who only calls
15% of the time,
even with 9 and 10 M,
you should push
100% of the time.
Why?
It's because 85% of the time,
he's just going to fold,
and even when you're
called, the amount
of value you get from him
folding most of the time
just crushes him.
So you should-- to the
extent that you can encourage
him to be tight, do it.
But absolutely, if he's
tight, push every single hand.
You're never in the scenario
where pushing less than top 50%
is good.
So that's it for heads up.
So now let's talk
about other positions,
and we end up in a lot of
complicated situations, which
we have to just
assume away here.
So we can lose in
two different ways.
We can lose if we
call and he beats us,
or we could also lose if we
call and then someone behind us
calls.
So we're estimating
that someone behind us
is only going to call if he has
a premium hand because if we're
in a short stack situation
and someone pushes
and then we call, someone is
only calling behind us when
they have a really good hand.
And let's just assume
we're going to lose
if we get another caller.
Like we are almost certainly
going to be dominated-- let's
say we have 0 EV there.
And because of our
equation here, we
can actually solve that.
We can actually figure
out what range is going
to be 60% versus another range.
So this is resulting in a really
cool rule of thumb here, which
is when you're in a
10 M or less situation
and you're trying to decide
whether to call an all-in, you
just ask yourself,
are you calling such
that his range is three
times more than your range?
And some questions you
might ask yourself is
say that you have Ace-10, like
you have a 10% range here.
Would he push all in into you
with King-Jack-- something
in a 30%?
If you have King-Queen,
which is like 30%,
would he push all in with 8-5,
which is 50% range, and so on.
So when you're in a
[? full ring ?] situation
and you're trying to
decide whether to call,
figure out in general
what do you think
his pushing range is there.
And it's a good call
if your calling range
is 1/3 of his pushing range.
Let's call it a day.
Thanks, guys.